26. I I like guys a little older than me
like most of us do yeah oh yeah girl so
yeah um so so let's say let's say 30
right let's say 30 and up that is a
little young okay
31st she's like I like everything
together I want to go for 70 year olds
she's lying she's lying so like there's
a minimum that he has to be at by 30.
but for me to date him like he's making
25 000 a year unless he just started a
business or something you know I'm just
thinking like what have you been doing
last 10 years yeah no I agree with that
and that's honest right so if if he's
not making 125 000 a year I'd be I I'm
fine like he can make 50 60 or you know
but I'm saying like what is the minimum
and he's 30. so he's like he's getting
up there in age I'm never gonna still
think it's so nuanced I don't think it's
on I'm never gonna have a woman coaching
me on my money that's not what I said I
would how you could help build a man
though we're not coaching him about his
money though what if I see a man who has
like really good qualities but there's I
don't know
um he gets angry a little bit does not
control his emotions if I have emotional
intelligence and I can be like oh here's
how you do this so that you could you
know not let your emotions get the best
of you in situations like I think
there's ways that you can support a man
when a man maybe doesn't feel good I
think there's a lot of things now out
with men where they feel insecure about
their place in the world with women who
are like I want the only one percent
male you know what I mean and I think I
think you can build a man by showing him
that he's worthy that you think he's
valuable I don't see because I'm just
thinking I'm thinking about you don't
need it no I'm just I'm thinking of the
men I know that like make six figures
you know or like the men I know they
were going to be successful with or
without them I've never dated a man that
says they haven't learned girl the girl
might have like helped thank you I've
never dated a man that says he hasn't
learned something from me that I didn't
provide value in that way I'm not saying
you can't learn anything I'm not I'm not
saying you can't learn anything from you
I'm not saying you can't you can't have
provided value in the relationship I'm
saying like a lot of times I think women
take credit for the men's success more
than they really deserve it's like yeah
you worked at his business or yeah you
helped him out but like he was gonna be
successful with or without you I think
that's completely disregarding the the
home like the Homemaker role so if this
is a man that gets to completely devote
his life to making money and she's
focused on building the family and
making sure he has meals three times a
day or what have you and she's really
building that home I think saying that
she didn't contribute to his success is
well then how are you going to have a
housekeeper a nanny a babysitter all of
that wrapped up in one and you just get
to work
we denying the fact that homemaking is a
complete job I absolutely love and adore
my wife she understands I was going to
be my I was going to be me regardless of
whether or not but then maybe you
wouldn't have had a family until you're
50. I was okay with not having a family
if that wasn't a criteria the the
determining factor for whether or not
she was going to come in or not okay I
was okay with not having a family my
goal was to get rich my goal was to be
successful I was going to be that with
or without her now it doesn't mean that
she doesn't add value or it doesn't mean
that I don't appreciate the fact that
she's a great mother or whatever so on
and so forth but she didn't make me cool
of course yeah absolutely and she can't
take credit for My Success either no
you're right no you did that correct but
she helped provide
what she benefits
like what did what did she do two things
can be true what did she do that a nanny
if she's a nanny no what did she do than
a nanny chef
and a maid couldn't so that's a that's a
good question is
huh is a housewife
no but she's you're providing for her
and then she's telling you and she's you
because she's providing no she's because
she didn't have problems too
well you know what well your way
no I think both parties you're not doing
me a favor yeah do a favor yeah but
there are definitely some relationships
where that is the case
no my whole point is like I just think a
lot of girls take credit for a guy's
success and well I think a lot of guys
will say their wife supported them and
helped them like I just think they're
going to be successful regardless again
build a man do you think that women it's
a lot it's a lot of use it's only one of
me
let's be clear
because a lot of chicks don't realize
that the guy is
the guy is the prize listen marriage is
more beneficial to women than it is to
men but if guys are the prize women like
men have wars over women no men lose
Wars over women
the downfall of every great Kingdom came
as a result of a man simping over a
woman
and placing more value over a woman than
he should and that's on the man that's
on the one which means that he should
have been more on his purpose instead of
focusing on a woman that sounds like a
him problem it is it is a him problem
maybe he's not but now but now the
difference is that guys are starting to
wake up and saying imma focus on the me
problem instead of focusing on her and
then it leaves a lot of y'all out in the
cold because y'all don't really
understand the value or you overvalue
what you bring into the household
because we don't in reality we got
doordash we got uh Zumba the room thing
that do the floor we got dishwashers
we don't even women are nurturers they
create they create life like to say that
to act like there's no value in that
completely diminishes what it means like
to be a woman and have like that role as
a woman yeah I'm not saying it's like
we're just like objects that you have to
like cater to you because you're
successful I'm not saying that like
women I'm not saying women bring no
value to these guys but I will say when
you actually talk to the Homemakers and
the women like you've I swear to God
I've never been humbled so quick I am
not no I've never been humbled so quick
when these women were telling me what
they do in a day it's like these women
make all their meals from scratch that
they got like this girl Gardens herself
yeah she Gardens herself she makes all
her meals from scratch she she cooks she
clean like oh my I mean I'm gonna have
her on the channel we're gonna do a wife
School episode that's a woman but I'm
just saying like most women don't bring
what a lot of these women bring to the
table I I absolutely agree that there is
there's some delusion in what
people provide in their value I don't
think it's all a delusion I don't think
it's that black and white and I think
that there's a lot of people you want to
talk about living in fairy tales like
men are living fairy tales they want
their stuff they want food they want
they want a maid they want they want
someone who it like doesn't take any
value or like any ownership of like what
they brought to the table being away you
just let me take big boobs and head no I
was repeating
everything that you just said you can do
within an hour
cook clean have within an hour you can
do all of that [__] within an hour it
takes have you done it
have you been married since you were 22
have you ever taken on that role of
sitting back and you be the the person
who's taking care of the kids and taking
care of the house because I absolutely
bet you wouldn't be able to do it the
way that a woman would do it take all of
that heat take all of that stress and
then still look at you as a man and make
you feel as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible